in a shocking development hunter biden
announces he's now being investigated by
the feds for tax
issues youtube announces it will crack
down on videos alleging election fraud
and trump's last ditch lawsuit strategy
comes down to texas i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
we're gonna get into all the news and
let me just tell you there will be some
hot fire today on
this show so hold on to your hats we'll
get to that in just
one second but first how about putting
some real silver in your loved one's
stocking
this year that is right now through
december 21st for every 5 000 bucks you
spend with birch gold group on physical
gold or silver
or investing in a precious metals high
right birch gold will send you bonus
silver which is an
awesome stocking stuffer especially
given the fact that you should be
diversifying anyway there's a lot of
uncertainty in today's market we have no
idea where coveted is going we have no
idea where we are going politically
everything is up in the air you should
put at least a little bit of your money
into precious metals and diversify
against the possibility of inflation
against the possibility of the stock
market dropping here's what you need to
do text spend 247
47 47 when you speak to your birch gold
representative let them know you want
the free silver with your purchase
even if you're investing in a precious
metals ira you still get the physical
silvers delivered directly
to your door i know the folks at birch
gold we've been working with them for
years tech spends
47 47 47 get a free information kit on
diversifying into gold from birch gold
they've got that a plus rating with the
better business bureau countless
five-star
reviews again we've been working with
them for years here at the ben shapiro
show text ben
to 47 47 47 open a precious metals ira
get your free silver before
december 21st our media they've declared
that they are the defenders of democracy
the slogan
the washington post adopted just after
trump's victory in 2016 was democracy
dies
in darkness democracy dies in darkness
and now our esteemed members of our
journalistic
establishment they have decided that
democracy is under threat it's under
threat because trump keeps talking about
election fraud
it's under threat because trump keeps
talking he keeps saying that the
election was stolen from him
and it doesn't matter that he's going
through a legal process and it doesn't
matter the electoral college will vote
it doesn't matter the states are
certifying this is all
a threat to democracy a deep dark threat
to democracy
pushing this agenda last night was of
course blockable chris cuomo
on cnn so here was chris cuomo last
night
laying out the case for ikea's an
officer of the court
is standing up for democracy this moment
we'll be remembered for what happens
next
and i want to be on record to you and to
all as an american
as a journalist and as an officer of the
court
trump and his party are trying to kill
our
democracy with these efforts and i
accuse them of this
high crime tonight this
is wrong okay now let me just say
in no uncertain terms these people are
full of so much crap
their eyes are now brown if they start
off as blue their eyes are turning brown
they are so full of crap that is
spilling out their ears from
boots to the top of their head they are
full of absolute unmitigated crap
okay the the fact is that if democracy
is dying it is largely
due to the effect of people who are
turning out the lights if democracy is
dying in darkness the people
who are enforcing the darkness are the
members of your esteemed
journalistic media your journalistic
establishment these objective
news reporters okay because as it turns
out
yesterday very late last night it broke
that hunter biden the president-elect
son
now says that federal prosecutors are
probing his taxes
now i'm old enough to remember when the
new york post was banned from twitter
because they posted a story about hunter
biden's laptop in which it talks about
the fact that he was engaged in a
nefarious goings-on
in foreign countries and that those
nefarious goings-on may have had some
tax consequences
in fact the new york post stories talked
about his connections with china
they talked about the possibility of
connections between joe biden
and his brother and his son and the new
york post stories talked about all this
and they were banned from twitter
facebook
preemptively decided to downgrade the
stories they said you know these haven't
been subjected to fact check yet
so pending a fact check we are
downgrading them meanwhile
members of that same established
journalistic
media the people who are guarding
democracy from the predations
of the evil trump cadre those same
jackasses
they were spending their days suggesting
that the new york post stories were
actually russian disinformation based on
nothing
based on literally nothing i mean if you
look at the headlines from the members
of the media before the election
here are some of those headlines here's
politico's headline hunter biden's story
is russian disinfo
dozens of former intel officials say
more than 50 former intelligence
officials
signed a letter casting doubt on the
providence of a new york post story on
the former vice president's son now at
no point did hunter biden ever
at any point deny that the laptop was
his or that material on the laptop was
his at no point did he offer a detailed
defense of his activities
nor at any point did he offer a detailed
explanation of what his relationship
was with joe biden and whether joe biden
knew that he was running around the
country and for and abroad
basically trafficking in trafficking in
daddy's name okay so now here is the
political headline today
justice department's interest in hunter
biden covered more than taxes
so what what changed question what
changed because the answer is nothing
it turns out that he has been under
investigation since 2018
since 2018. so your entire media
spent the last year and a half covering
up any allegations
of hunter biden's corruption or any
allegations that that corruption was
connected
in any way to joe biden and they
suggested it was russian disinformation
and they had other journalistic outlets
like the new york post downgraded or
suspended
and they banned the dissemination of the
story by twitter accounts and they did
all of these things
just before the election then the
election happens and oh look at that
politico is now reporting that the
justice department's interest in hunter
biden covered more than taxes
and these people have the temerity to
suggest that the threat to democracy is
coming from somewhere else
these folks are the threats to democracy
when your media
who are charged with providing you
information decide that they are going
to be the arbiters of what information
you are allowed to see
and not only that they're going to bully
social media companies into ensuring
that you can't see the alternative
information because remember it's not
just the places like the new york times
and cbs news
and politico and all these other
journalistic outlets refused to report
certain facts about hunter biden and
investigate certain facts about hunter
biden
is that they actively stumped to prevent
social media from disseminating
information from websites like the daily
wire
the fact of the matter is that the new
york times has several activists on its
payroll
whose sole job apparently is just to
lobby facebook to downgrade traffic
from places like the daily wire these
are the people who are the threats to
democracy you wonder why there's no
systemic trust you wonder why the trust
in institutions is way down because it's
not just that people don't trust the
media anymore
it's that anything the media talk about
is now tainted
okay if the media say that the election
is fraud the election is fraudulent we
don't believe you and if the media say
that the election is good we are also
not going to believe you because we
don't trust you
see it's not just that the media's
disgusting and nefarious partisanship
masquerading as objectivity impacts how
we view the media
is that whenever the media says
something about another topic we now no
longer believe what they have to say
because after all our news media are
supposed to be our prism into the rest
of the world so if we believe that the
prism is broken
if we believe that the glasses that the
media are providing to us
our sunglasses and they're blocking out
light that's going to affect
our interpretation of facts across the
spectrum it's going to lower our trust
in other institutions if the media say
people we don't trust say
you should trust x we're going to say we
don't trust x anymore that's what's
happening here
if there is a decline in institutional
trust in america and there certainly is
it begins with the media but it doesn't
stop there
it is now infused into the bloodstream
of
the american political system again
just as if you knew you had a friend
okay and it turns out that your friend
was a liar and a cheat
and your friend then came to you and you
knew there's a liar on the cheat and he
said you know who you should trust
you should trust this guy over here
would you trust that guy the answer is
probably now maybe you should trust the
guy
maybe that guy's actually a good guy
maybe your friend the liar and cheat
is actually right in this one
circumstance but you have no way of
telling that
and if it turns out that your friend the
liar cheat has also restricted your
access
to other information to verify whether
this third party is good or bad
then you are more likely than not to not
believe what he has to say
that is the mainstream media today
that's the mainstream media the
mainstream media are not merely
about not providing you the facts
they're about actively covering up the
facts
preventing themselves from investigating
the facts throwing journalists like
sheryl atkinson out of work
if they tried to investigate particular
stories and then going to social media
companies and trying to prevent you
from getting another story from another
group of people that's what they do
and then they put democracy dies in
darkness at the head of their fake
newspapers it's ridiculous
and when i say that the washington post
is a fake newspaper i don't mean that
there aren't great investigative
journalists of the washington post this
is the sad part
a lot of what people do at the
washington post is useful the same thing
is true
of many of the reporters at the new york
times but when you overall
turn your brand into basically a
mouthpiece for the democratic party it
makes it impossible for people to
distinguish
what is true from what is false makes
impossible for people to trust you on
any issue
ranging from how we should act with
regard to covid to how we should believe
you with regard to
foreign interference in american
elections we just don't know
what to believe and then when you use
censorship in order to quash everybody
else
it makes us suspicious that you are
seriously lying to us we'll get to more
of this in a second because
i'm going to bring in the details of
this hunter biden story it's it's
amazing
all this stuff was available before the
election and don't tell me
that it doesn't affect an election when
you prevent the public from seeing
things what happened is that in 2016
the media actually sort of did their
jobs by reporting on hillary clinton's
emails and then they were so regretful
of the fact that trump was elected
they decided they would never again
cover a story that hurt a democrat
in the last month of a campaign it's
that simple that's all that happened
here and you could see it
you could see it you could see it
because any time anybody mentioned
anything about hunter biden like when
maggie haberman tweeted out the hunter
biden story from the new york post
she was immediately swamped with a
tsunami of other journalists
telling her not to do it these are
activists they are not journalists
they are damned liars and they are
destroying the basis for
the fundamental basis of a democracy
because again it is one thing to have a
variety of news sources you pick from
it's another thing to have a dominant
establishment media that prevents you
from seeing any of the other sources
that are available to you and that's
what's going
on we'll get some more of this in just
one second
first let's talk about the fact that if
you're running a business there's one
set of issues you don't think about too
much but it can absolutely destroy your
business i'm talking of course about hr
issues they can kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations and hr
managers salaries aren't cheap then an
average of seventy thousand bucks a year
bambi spelled bam be was created
specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy and maintain your compliance
all for just 99 bucks a month with bambi
you can change hr from your biggest
liability to your biggest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day we're all for just 99 bucks a
month
month to month no hidden fees you can
cancel anytime you didn't start your
business because you want to spend time
on hr compliance nobody does but if you
don't spend the time
if you don't spend the resources it can
come back to bite you so why would you
spend a bajillion dollars on it instead
head on over to bambi.com
shapiro right now schedule that free hr
audit again that's bambi.com
shapiro b-a-m-b-e-e dot com
shapiro to get started to clear up all
of your hr issues quickly and easily
bambi.com
shapiro okay so here is the actual story
according to nbc news
they're allowed to report it now it's
okay it's okay guys the election's over
they're allowed to now let the light
flourish
here's darth neural clark tom winter and
mike mimoli reporting
hunter biden president's electro biden's
son said wednesday federal
officials in delaware are investigating
his taxes now number one
weird that we're finding this out from
hunter biden isn't it in that strange
i normally find this out from leaks via
the justice department
or maybe from the justice department
directly but in this particular case
hunter biden is announcing he's under
investigation
how strange almost as though he is
getting special treatment
hunter biden said quote i learned
yesterday for the first time that the
u.s attorney's office in delaware
advised my legal counsel also yesterday
that they are investigating my tax
affairs
i take this matter very seriously but i
am confident a professional and
objective review of these matters will
demonstrate i handled my affairs legally
and appropriately including with the
benefit of professional
tax advisors the u.s attorney for
delaware's office declined to comment on
an ongoing
investigation this news came weeks after
an election campaign in which president
donald trump and his allies made
unfounded and baseless claims of
corruption regarding hunter biden and
his father
how do you know if they're unfounded and
baseless if you refuse to do the basic
reporting
nbc news and what exactly are the
unfounded baseless
claims would that be that perhaps joe
biden
knew about what his son was doing
because that was not unfounded and
baseless
i mean that's exactly what hunter
biden's business partner tony bobolinsky
was saying publicly
that was not unfounded and baseless but
the media treated it as unfounded and
baseless
because they obviously have a dog in
this fight they allege that hunter biden
used his father's influence to enrich
himself through business deals in
ukraine in china and that his father not
only facilitated but that he may have
benefited financially
trump provided no evidence for these
claims okay
even in the story you can see the absurd
anti-factual bias
they allege hunter biden used his
father's influence to enrich himself
through business deals in ukraine they
didn't allege that hunter biden overtly
admitted that in a public interview on
national television they asked hunter
biden would you have gotten a job
on the burisma board having no
experience in natural oil or gas or
ukraine
if your dad's name weren't biden he said
absolutely not
of course he was using his father's
influence of course
he was doing all of these things we know
that there are companies
founded and in their founding documents
that talked about using hunter biden's
influence with daddy and in washington
dc
we know that is the case because we have
seen the documents
and now we are being told by nbc news
that the trump campaign was making those
baseless allegations they weren't
baseless you guys just didn't want to
investigate them
you didn't want to report them you still
don't want to report them
that's not an allegation that he used
his dad's name to get rich in ukraine
that is an actual fact that he has
admitted to
however says nbc news hunter and his
ex-wife kathleen buell
had an internal revenue service lean
against them for taxes not paid
possibly including interest in penalties
totaling 112 000 until this past march
according to publicly available
documents the documents filed by the irs
show the tax lien was placed on hunter
and buell in november of 2019.
it is not immediately clear if the lien
has anything to do with the
investigation
the biden team then put out this
pathetic statement quote
president-elect biden is deeply proud of
his son who has fought through difficult
challenges including the vicious
personal attacks of recent months
only to emerge stronger well listen he's
a good dad he's got a right to
be proud of his son i'm not sure what
about hunter biden would make you proud
it's not like there's a lot there that
make you proud of hunter but with that
said
the idea that these were vicious
personal attacks no that's just called
reporting
especially when it turns out that the
entire biden clan
and this has been widely reported
everywhere from the left to the right
including a big new yorker story just a
couple of years ago the entire biden
clan
has has used its influence and it's an
and daddy's name in order to get rich
okay that is
unchallengeable now it turns out there's
even more to the story
so cnn now they're allowed to
investigate right cnn's allowed to cover
this now so after
months of suggesting that any questions
about hunter biden were simply
made up and we should just ignore them
because it was a distraction from
trump's threat to democracy
now we've got evan perez and pamela
brown at cnn reporting
after going quiet in the months before
the election federal authorities are now
actively investigating the business
dealings of hunter biden
a person with knowledge of the probe
said his father president-elect joe
biden is not implicated
now that the election is over the
investigation is entering a new phase
federal prosecutors in delaware working
with the irs criminal investigation
agency and the fbi are taking overt
steps such as issuing subpoenas and
seeking interviews the person with
knowledge said
now i have a question why did they wait
until the election was over
why seriously what is the rationale
because they wanted your bite to win end
of story
that's all typically legal
investigations do not get held up
contingent
on the person's proximity to an election
that's insane
that's an insane act of corruption do
you understand how crazy that is
that if you had prosecutors who are on
the trail of a candidate or a
candidate's family member and they
decided you know we're putting this off
until after the election because we just
don't want to interfere in the election
that is election interference that's
election interference
if ivanka trump had committed a crime
and she were under investigation and the
fed said you know what there's an
election coming up we're just going to
put this thing off until like just
after the election that would be
election interference the same is
obviously true of hunter biden
in the first three paragraphs of the cnn
story they mentioned the election
three times three times in three
paragraphs the relevance of the election
quote activity in the investigation had
gone covert in recent months
due to justice department guidelines
prohibiting overt actions that could
affect an election the person said
so first of all if there are actual
guidelines from the justice department
saying you can't take
overt action meaning you can't take
perfectly legal action because it might
affect an election that affects an
election
what actually happened here is members
of the doj decided that they didn't want
to get caught in the james comey trap of
having to publicly investigate one of
the candidates or a family member of the
candidates they didn't want the heat
they didn't want all of the rage brought
about and so they said you know we're
going to bury this until after the
election
and the media did the exact same thing
we're not going to cover this until
after the election
and now the election is over and guess
what now the doj can move forward
and we're supposed to trust the media
and we're supposed to trust these
legal institutions that apparently are
dedicated to not affecting an election
by directly impacting an election
that's ins this is all madness this is
all madness
and then you wonder why there are
conspiracy theories blooming you wonder
why people are suspicious
of election fraud you wonder why people
don't trust the system
maybe because if you don't trust the
media or the prism to view the system
and if it turns out
that members of the system are engaged
in corrupt activities
they were in 2016 with regard to going
after carter page with a bad fisa
warrant
with regard to pumping the steele
dossier through the federal government
via a hillary clinton law firm
if you don't trust the system because of
that and if you don't trust the system
because before the 2020 election they
decided they were not going to
investigate hunter biden because it was
too close to the election
it might be that somebody might draw the
perfectly
understandable if incorrect conclusion
that the entire system
is just not worth thrusting
how many times can you go back to the
well before people say you know what
we're done
that's one of the things that is
happening here so now cnn contacted
biden's attorney in the campaign this
week
seeking comments about the investigation
on wednesday they released a statement
acknowledging the problem okay so this
is the key
right there okay that is the key it is
not that hunter biden was the first
person to find out about the
investigation
cnn knew about the investigation
they say so they openly admit it in the
cnn story again let me read that more
slowly
cnn contacted biden's attorney and the
campaign this week
seeking comment about the investigation
on wednesday which would be after cnn
contacted them they released a statement
acknowledging the probe
oh look at that that means the media
hunter was not the first to know the
media knew as well
members of cnn reportorial gang knew
which means
they could have known before the
election because guess what this
investigation has been ongoing according
to cnn since 2018
this is madness we'll get to more of
this in just one second if you're not
mad you're not watching
seriously you should be pissed when
people talk about rigging the election
you know people talk about voter fraud
or voter irregularity no the way that
you rig an election is by taking
the entire media infrastructure using it
as cover for the democratic candidate
hiding all the information and then as
we will see trying to mobilize social
media to crack down on anybody who'd
actually report that information
that's how you rig an election the way
you rig an election is by preventing the
american public from seeing information
that they need to see
meanwhile focusing all of your ira on
one candidate
the media decided this election period
end of story
that is what happened here aided and
abetted by people apparently
in the justice department i'm not saying
the hunter biden thing would have swung
the election to trump
i'm saying there there's a consistent
pattern of the media refusing to report
anything about joe biden anything at
all okay and there's a consistent
pattern of social media
attempting to downgrade information
unfavorable toward democratic candidates
and this has an impact we'll get to more
of this in just one second first
now you've been staring at screens all
day long i mean many of us across the
country been locked in our homes for
months on end this means you're spending
an awful lot of time with screens you
may have noticed that you've been
getting headaches from it this is
because of the blue light okay it's been
shown that blue light can actually cause
headaches it can prevent you from
sleeping well
this is why you need felix gray glasses
they filter 15 times more blue light
from screens than other clear
blue light lenses to help restore your
balance the original optical lenses
relieve
most eye strain symptoms from daily
screen time the more advanced sleep
glasses actually relieve
serious daily eye strain and more
especially designed for late night
screen time to improve your sleep
these also happen to look great the
felix gray frames they are hand finished
from italian acetate makes them durable
lightweight super comfortable
the blue light lenses come standard
starting at 95 bucks
or you can add your prescription to
check out starting at 145 bucks if you
don't love those glasses
in the first 30 days their in-house
customer care team will take care of
exchanges and returns
no hassle and no questions asked you got
nothing to lose except that headache get
a pair of glasses
designed for the 21st century get five
percent off your order when go to
felixgrayglasses.com enter chrome promo
code ben at checkout again
that is f-e-l-i-x-g-r-a-y glasses dot
com slash ben
and five percent off promo code ben i
check out free shipping free exchange's
30 day money back guarantee felix
grayglasses.com
promo code ben makes a great christmas
gift go check them out right now okay so
the cnn story continues they say
hints of the investigation emerge after
president donald trump's personal
attorney rudy giuliani helped
orchestrate news stories centered on a
laptop
purporting to belong to hunter biden and
said to include his business documents
and other personal material again look
how cnn twists the story here right
they don't report the contents of the
laptop they don't suggest that
the stories were true because they were
instead it was that all of these stories
were orchestrated orchestrated by rudy
giuliani oh i look forward to hearing
how the entire russian
dossier was orchestrated by hillary
clinton because it was
hillary clinton and her and her law firm
and through which she was laundering the
steele dossier
you didn't hear this kind of language
from cnn about steele dossier the fbi
took possession of the laptop in late
according to a computer repairman in
delaware who showed reporters a copy of
a subpoena
the subpoena is real according to people
briefed on the matter but the fbi and
prosecutors in delaware have refused to
confirm the existence of the
investigation
it's unclear whether the laptop's
contents are relevant to the ongoing
federal probe
and whether investigators can even use
them given potential chain of custody
requirements for evidence
cnn has previously reported that at
least some of the information giuliani
claims came from the laptop
appears similar to information that was
being shared by others last year in
ukraine
giuliani's efforts to dig up dirt on the
bidens in ukraine last year with the
heart of trump's impeachment the current
investigation in tantra biden
appears to predate those efforts and so
this is cnn attempting to defend its own
shoddy work
in suggesting that the entire story was
russian disinformation when it turns out
that
every element of the story was
apparently true
the involvement of trump lawyers in the
published news stories on the purported
biden laptop
led to a flurry of activity by
republican lawmakers and the trump
campaign
looking to amplify allegations of
corruption ahead of the election
the fbi met with a former hunter-biden
business associate who publicly made
claims about potential wrongdoing
the fbi issued a statement at the time
saying quote as a general matter when
contacted the fbi reviews information
from the public for consideration
of any violations of applicable federal
laws the political implications of the
probe already have been an issue in
recent months for william barr the ag
who is under public pressure from trump
to make hunter biden's business
activities and election issue
today the investigation does not involve
any allegations of wrongdoing by the
president-elect according to the two
main sources briefed on the matter
okay but here is the key of the story
are you ready investigators appear to be
focused on hunter biden's business
activities connected to
china again this is a key element of the
new york post story
media went nuts and the fact is that
hunter biden was involved in nefarious
activity
in china which we all knew because he
was taking air force two with
dad to china to secure billion-dollar
loan deals
or at least investments some of his
business dealings in china are publicly
known through interviews and documents
released in september by senate
republicans on the finance committee
and the committee on homeland security
and government affairs says cnn
after his father left office in 2017
hunter biden worked on securing a deal
with cefc china energy
to invest in u.s energy products
according to documents released by
republicans
at least one of the matters
investigators have examined is a 2017
gift of a 2.8 carat diamond hunter
received from cefc's founder and former
chairman
yi xiaoming after a miami business
meeting one person briefed on the matter
said
in 2019 biden provided the new yorker
magazine an account
receiving that diamond from yi he told
the new yorker he felt uncomfortable
receiving it and gave it to other
associates he doesn't know what they did
with it
i knew it wasn't a good idea to take it
it just felt weird he said in his new
yorker interview
apparently he said the cefc deal fell
through he didn't consider yi to be a
shady character chinese authorities
later detangly amid chinese media
reports of corruption allegations
against him receiving such a gift could
have potential tax
implications of course sources say that
investigators have been looking into
whether biden properly reported his
income for tax purposes
over a period of time also hunter biden
had been involved in an earlier chinese
business venture that drew concerns in
the obama white house and joe biden
staff according to the new yorker in
2013 hunter biden became involved with
u.s and chinese partners who were
creating an investment fund
called bhr partners for deals outside of
china hunter biden was an unpaid member
of the bhr board and took an equity
stake after daddy left office according
to the new yorker now it's okay for the
cnn report all this right
at the time it was just a big a big
distraction from all the election issues
now it's okay to report it the
election's over but you should trust
these people you should trust the media
we'll get some more of this insanity i
mean it really is it should give you
heartburn
how much you have been lied to here it
should give you heartburn how much
people who claim to be objective have
become just mouthpieces for the
democrats and then decide their timing
based on elections
first let us talk for a second about the
best clothes available i'm talking about
cuts clothing
for better or worse 2020 has kicked off
the work from home era everybody is
asking one big question what exactly are
you supposed to wear
do you need to wear a tie for your zoom
meeting probably not but you actually
don't want to wear like sweatpants and a
beautiful t-shirt
instead you need cuts clothing it is the
perfect solution to your work from home
wardrobe confusion cuts is the best in
the world they make technical apparel
for the sport of business they got
t-shirts
polos hoodies these things are quality
they've got style you can wear them in
the office on a date anywhere in between
i basically only wear cuts clothing in
2016 steven burelli was struggling to
find the perfect t-shirt he wanted
something
that had enough quality to be worn
professionally at work but enough style
for a night out
he couldn't find anything to fit the
bill so he took matters into his own
hands cuts started in 2016
making what gq calls the only shirt
worth wearing
athletic tailored looking fit it's
perfect for work date everything
in between they're custom engineered
wrinkle-free
pika pro fabric can only be described as
buttery soft it really is incredibly
soft it fits
incredibly incredibly well and right now
they've released their new pika polos
they're designed in la with cuts custom
engineered pika pro fabric that keeps
you fitted for the daily work grind
they've got hoodies they're made from
their hyperloop
french terry fabric i mean this stuff is
just super comfortable and it looks
great cuts is loved by your favorite
athletes entrepreneurs and even podcast
hosts like me
seems like everybody is wearing cuts
these days get 15 off your first order
by going to cutsclothing.com
shapiro that is cutsclothing.com shapiro
for 15
off the only shirt worth wearing makes a
fantastic holiday gift
okay so the way cnn covers this of
course
is that it's very it's it's very sad for
joe biden that's the way cnn covers this
according to cnn.com in an interview
with cnn's jake tapper last week
president-elect biden pledged to
maintain an independent doj free of
political influence uh-huh
sure sure republicans in congress says
cnn are almost certain to seize on the
existence of the probe
it's all every time democrats do a bad
thing it means that republicans are
about to pounce
like little kittens pounds they're going
to pounce or alternatively
joe biden's son is corrupt as the day is
long republicans in congress says cnn
are almost certain disease on the
existence of the probe to further their
argument that hunter biden's activities
in china are a sign of his father's
conflict of interest when it comes to
dealing with foreign policy with beijing
well i mean
that would seem to be an issue would it
not considering that we now have
information that not only
have the chinese deployed spies that
successfully infiltrated the offices
of both eric swallow and apparently the
bad allegedly of eric swalwell as well
as the office of senator dianne
feinstein we know from intelligence
reports the chinese desperately wanted
joe biden to win this election
so maybe some suspicion would be
warranted funny because we got four
years of suspicion that trump was a
russian agent
now of course we're supposed to just
dismiss all possibility
that perhaps joe biden could be
influenced by the fact that the chinese
were so sweet to his son
it's likely going to be an issue that
biden's a.g nominee will have to face
during a senate confirmation hearing
according to cnn
biden's likely attorney general
candidates uh will probably not be
recusing themselves in the same way that
jeff sessions did because he's a member
of the campaign
but this whole thing it just stinks it
stinks to high heaven
the hold up stinks to high heaven joseph
simonson
and and jerry dunleavy of the washington
examiner reporting back in october
that hunter biden was aiming to avoid
violating the foreign corrupt practices
act
in pursuit of chinese business deals so
it's not like this stuff wasn't known
months ago before the
before the election it was it was
reported it just wasn't reported by any
of the sources
that facebook wanted you to see
according to the washington examiner
again this is late october hunter biden
made it clear
one of his goals was for him and his
associates to avoid violating the
anti-bribery
foreign corrupt practices act or having
to register as foreign agents
as he pursued potentially lucrative
deals with a chinese communist party
connected company
according to newly released texts from
ex-business partner tony babilinski
no matter what it will need no matter
what it will need to be a u.s company at
some level in order for us to make bids
on federal and state funded projects
also
we don't want to have to register as
foreign agents under the fcpa which is
much more expansive than people who
should know
choose not to know james has very
particular opinions about this so i'd
ask him about the foreign entity
biden texted bobolinsky on may 1st 2017.
regardless we should have a delaware
corporation called cefc america and
ownership should be
50 me 50 them we then cut up our 50 in a
separate entity between the four of us
create that company call it bwbg or
whatever it's just a pass-through
so um they were openly talking about how
to game at the foreign corrupt
practices act and all this could have
been reported by you know mainstream
media sites all of these texts were
available
all of the stuff these emails were
available bob linski was doing
interviews
and uh yet it didn't it didn't none of
it mattered amazing
just just amazing because the media were
more focused on protecting
joe biden's electoral chances than
reporting the news to you it is simply
that easy it's that easy speaking of
which
it is not merely that your establishment
media have decided that
it is important that you view only what
they allow you to view they've decided
that you are not allowed to view
things that they don't want you to view
so this is an amazing amazing clip that
i'm about to play for you
so there there's a man named steve cole
steve cole is the dean of columbia
graduate school of journalism
right this is captain journalism over
here steve cole he was on msnbc the
other day and this really does
explain where your journalistic betters
lie it is not merely that they wish to
provide you a filter
it's that they wish to prevent you from
accessing other sources of information
so he literally says this is the dean of
the graduate school of journalism at
columbia university perhaps the most
prestigious
journalism school in america suggesting
that freedom of speech is itself a
problem
freedom of speech is a problem because
then you might not get the sort of
journalism you're used to from your
objective news sources
right all the people who are journalism
all over the place all the people
pleasuring themselves jeffrey tube and
style to pictures
of the democratic campaign all of those
people wouldn't be your only source and
that's bad we don't want that to happen
says the dean of the columbia graduate
school of journalism here's steve cole
summing up the position of so many of
our journalistic veterans
those of us in journalism have to come
to terms with the fact that
free speech a principle that we hold
sacred is being weaponized against
the principles of journalism and what do
we do about that
i just say you know as as reporters we
kind of march into this
war with our facts uh nobly shouldered
as if
they were going to win the day and what
we're seeing is that
because of the scale of this alternate
reality that you've been talking about
our facts our principles our scientific
method
it isn't enough so what do we do so what
do we do and the answer is what they do
is they try to pressure social media
into preventing other people from
reporting
this is something we've been
experiencing with facebook for the last
several months right right before the
election and then right after the
election it turns out that according to
the new york times
facebook changed its algorithm to
elevate news
sources that they deemed to be high
quality what were those high-quality
news sources
hmm let's think about oh look at that
it's the new york times
shocker so the new york times has kevin
roose out there every day
yelling that people like me like my
facebook page has wide reach
that's bad dan bongino he has wide reach
that's bad
fox news has wide reach that's super bad
and then facebook magically changes its
algorithm right before the election and
right in the aftermath of the election
to downgrade the news sources that you
like
in favor of news sources you're trying
to avoid by going to facebook in the
first place and who's pressuring them to
do that
you're betters in the media they love
speech restrictions
it's not that they are opposed to speech
restrictions they just don't want speech
restrictions on them but for everybody
else they're in favor of speech
restrictions
now notice the inconsistency here i have
defended at every step of the way
the right of the new york times to
publish whatever the damn hell it wants
i've defended the rights of people i
radically disagree with
to cover things in ways that i radically
disagree they have that right
i think they're wrong to cover things
the way they cover them but they have
absolutely that right i've never called
for the downgrading of a journalistic
source or an opinion
news source on places like facebook or
youtube or twitter i've defended people
from exactly that sort of stuff hell
i've defended people that i think
have horrible evil views from being
fired from their jobs
if their horrible evil views have
nothing to do with their jobs
and that is the way that you you should
act if you're a first amendment advocate
but that's not the way the democrats act
that's not the way members of the media
act members of the media
are interested in changing your mind
about the issues and the best way to
change your mind is to close your mind
and the best way to close your mind is
to prevent you from seeing any
alternative sources
of information which is why we should
see it as somewhat dangerous
that the biden team has now appointed
rick stengel
as the under secretary of state for
public diplomacy and public affairs
he was done that he had that job
actually under obama
in 2013 and now apparently
stengel is on biden's transition team to
head the u.s agency for global media an
agency that oversees quote
public service media networks that
provide unbiased news
and information in countries where the
press is restricted
so he's very much in favor of open
journalism and free speech and news
reporting
except for the fact that in 2011 he
wrote a time cover piece
featuring a picture of the constitution
and a headline saying does it still
matter
in that piece he said quote we can pat
ourselves on the back about the past 223
years but we cannot let the constitution
become an obstacle
to the us's moving into the future with
a sensible healthcare system
a globalized economy an evolving sense
of civil and political rights
the constitution does not protect our
spirit of liberty our spirit of liberty
protects the constitution
the constitution serves the nation the
nation does not serve
the constitution so the constitution is
completely malleable and then in 2019 he
went further here's what he argued in an
op-ed for the washington post quote
as a government official traveling
around the world championing the virtues
of free speech i came to see how our
first amendment standard is an outlier
even the most sophisticated arab
diplomats that i dealt with did not
understand why the first amendment
allows someone to burn a quran
why they asked me would you ever want to
protect that
okay so the the supposed defenders of
free speech inside the biden team
are openly saying that they don't like
free speech
that they think free speech is bad that
free speech ought to be quashed
not by the way just to affect american
elections apparently but also
to avoid offending the sensibilities of
people in other countries
okay th this is is what we're supposed
to believe that these people stand for
american values by the way that that
was from a david harsany's piece in
national review november 11th 2020.
the fact of the matter is this your
media trying to shut you down which
brings us to youtube so we'll come to
youtube
in just one second because youtube has
now set a brand new magical standard
on what sort of videos they are going to
take down we'll get to that in just
one moment first let us talk about your
sleep quality so i will admit to you
i'm in a bad mood not just because of
the news today and the fact that you're
being lied to on a regular basis by
people who are not supposed to lie to
you
but also because my kids woke me up like
a thousand times last night so my baby
daughter woke us up at 11 30. then she
wakes up at 2 30 then she will go to
5 30. well in those fleeting moments
between being woken up i needed to sleep
and this is why i relied on my
personalized mattress from helix sleep
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete
it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you're getting
a mattress you know will be perfect for
the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from
they have soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been awesome getting unboxing
videos from so many of you you've got in
your helix sleep mattress it's really
cool you unbox it it just inflates right
in front of you
it's awesome if you're looking for a
mattress take the quiz order the
mattress and the mattress comes right to
your doorstep for free
you don't need to go to a mattress store
ever again helix is awesome you don't
need to take my word for it they were
given the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine head on over to helixsleep.com
take that two minute sleep quiz and
change your sleep quality for the rest
of your life they've got a 10-year
warranty you have to try it out for 100
nights risk-free
they'll pick it up for you if you don't
love it you will helix is offering up to
200 bucks off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helix sleep.com
that is helixsleep.com for 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
when you access that deal helix sleep
dot com slash ben all right we're gonna
get to
youtube's new restrictions on what sort
of content they will allow
to be posted we'll get to that in just
one second first if you're not already a
daily where i remember
you need to join right now i mean the
main pitch honestly for joining is not
even all the new content we're bringing
which i'll get to in just one second
it is the fact that the very
establishment media that is restricting
your right
to get information that is militantly
attempting to shut the access to
information
those people have to be stopped they do
and the best way to stop them
is by joining up with organizations like
daily wire to fight them
on every front to provide an alternative
source of information because they just
won't bring you all the information to
provide you an alternative source of
culture
because the cultural wars are on you you
need to join the fight and one of the
ways you join the fight is by helping
companies like this one
bring you the information that you need
because i promise you they're going to
try
they have been they're gonna try to shut
off the spigots that you actually cannot
see our information
this is the next step we'll talk about
that in a second on the show but by the
way when you subscribe you also get a
bunch of goodies so for example
we are adding the entire prageru catalog
to dailywire.com the michael knowles
show is now five days a week which is
more content for our members to enjoy
i'm gonna be doing new stuff next year
candace owens is joining at the daily
wire in nashville we are launching our
first feature film
under daily wires upcoming entertainment
channel i've seen it it's kind of
awesome we're building a new
investigative journalism team so you
don't have to rely
on these jokers who will suppress
information prior to an election so
go outside the narrative head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe
and join the fight also have you seen
this thing look at this
indeed this is the new improved leftist
tears tumbler
and keep those leftist years hot or cold
in a new stainless steel design with
that custom daily wire lid
this is snazzy stuff and you get that
when you become a subscriber so head on
over to dailywire.com
subscribe right now you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay the fact that the media suppressed
all this stuff is not
the whole story it's also the big tech
suppressed it remember the new york post
was banned from twitter their account
was shut for trying to report the hunter
biden story
if you tried to tweet out that story
they suppressed your tweet
hey remember that facebook preemptively
shut down the hunter biden story they
said pending the fact check before there
was even a fact check
before there was a fact check they shut
down the the
distribution of the information it's
absolutely mad maddening
it is madness the fact that anybody
trusts these jokers in in big tech
or in social media or in the press is
beyond me
why would you possibly trust them okay
well now youtube has announced that it's
changing its policies
okay so here is what they just released
they released this statement yesterday
quote we just shared an update on
youtube's election efforts including
how we're handling community guidelines
pertaining to election-related
misinformation
our policies disallow content alleging
that widespread fraud or errors change
the outcome of a historical us
presidential election
we allow this type of commentary for
current elections as election officials
work to finalize counts
december 8th was the safe harbor
deadline for the u.s presidential
election
states need to resolve contested
elections by then and enough states have
now certified their election results to
determine
a president-elect okay so just to be
fair
we should note at this point that the
election date
the date in which the election is
essentially over is not december 8th
that's the safe harbor provision
court challenges could still overturn
safe harbor provisions december 14th
when the electoral college votes
that is when this sucker is over okay so
they're preemptively declaring it over
obviously because
if we're going to just talk about legal
dates december 8th does not mean nearly
as much as december 14th when the
electoral college actually meets to vote
and even that doesn't mean as much as i
believe january 6th
when that final electoral college vote
is certified i believe by the house of
representatives is the way the process
works
but youtube is taking pre-emptive action
they say as such starting today we will
remove new content uploaded on or after
december 9th
2020 alleging that widespread fraud or
errors changed the outcome
of the 2020 u.s presidential election
for example
we'll remove videos claiming that a
presidential candidate won the election
as a result
of widespread software glitches or
counting errors this is in line with our
approach toward historical us
presidential elections
content that includes sufficient context
may remain on youtube similar to how we
allow covet-19 medical misinformation
that violates our policies to exist
in videos with other contexts that
debunks it for example if your content
is impacted you'll receive automated
emails from our system regarding this
content
as we ramp up our enforcement we'll
initially remove violated videos without
giving a strike
after inauguration day we'll start
giving strikes and taking down accounts
basically
okay so a couple of things here they're
not going to move a single video
claiming that donald trump is not the
legitimate president of the united
states in 2016 not one
now one of those gonna come down so it's
only a certain type
of election fraud it's only a certain
type of claiming an election was
illegitimate they're going to take down
so if you say that this election was
fraudulent because of
vote counts or because of voter fraud or
regularity by the way
all claims i'm skeptical of as you know
if you say that
youtube will take down the video if
however you say georgia
georgia's non-governor stacey abrams is
actually the governor of georgia thanks
to voter suppression that stays up
i mean hell that was part of the dnc we
can't take that down if you say
that donald trump was the illegitimate
president of the united states because
the russians interfered in the election
are they going to leave that up how what
if you allege that donald trump
was was made president because of
russian interference in the election not
indirectly but directly like they messed
with the vote counts is youtube gonna
take that down
not that i'm aware of okay this is your
social media bettors
deciding what you can and cannot see by
the way it's not gonna kill conspiracy
theories
do you really think that the way that
you are going to kill dissemination of
information like this
theories about the the stealing of the
us election you think that you are going
to kill those theories
by having liberals who all gave money to
joe biden suppress the information
good luck with that seriously good luck
but this is the goal
and it all ties into this basic idea
that if you are on the right and
it won't stop there by the way and and
the left doesn't want it to stop there
because they simply label anything they
don't like this information it'd be one
thing if they were actually exact in
their in their
labeling of disinformation they are not
they claimed the hunter biden story was
disinformation
they had a blanket shut down on the
hunter biden story they downgraded
content
the big tech bros and now we're supposed
to believe they're going to restrict it
to you know well-verified claims
by the way they've even gained that
system the way that facebook works this
thing
is that they actually allow left-wing
fact-checkers to ding particular news
sites
in order to downgrade their content on
facebook so they just outsource the
dinging
they outsource the censorship and then
they claim oh we're not in control of
that i mean obviously listen we have our
factcheck.org folks over there and they
say
daily wire is not as credible as cnn and
we believe them because their name is
fact check it's right there in the name
this is all bullcrap it's all bullcrap
it is designed to restrict your access
it is designed to pervert how democracy
is supposed to work
free flow of information access to
information
now does that mean that the solution is
going to be federal regulation
i i have doubts about that because i
think that democrats are likely to take
over the auspices of running these
companies i think that
if you create a media oversight watchdog
right social media oversight watchdog in
the federal government
sooner or later elizabeth warren ends up
running it and then they just restrict
it from government as opposed to the
sort of social restriction
outside but should there be liability
for companies that effectively promised
their consumers that they were going to
have free and access free and open
access
to information so long as it was not
defamatory
i i i don't see why there shouldn't be
some sort of lo of liability from
customers were promised something and
given something else
i think beyond that the the main theme
here is that you got to find alternative
sources of information
it sounds self-serving but it happens to
be true so i'm going to make it broader
than this you need to go subscribe
not just to daily wire to blaze tv you
need to go subscribe over to daily
caller you need to go subscribe over at
breitbart like any place that you want
alternative source of information you
need to go subscribe today
because the bottom line is that they are
going to try to shut down all
dissemination of information
this is what they do it's what they are
interested
in doing and then they wonder why people
are so
skeptical of the of the media and not
only the media all of the institutions
surrounding the media because we're
being gaslit we're being guests
let me give you a great example okay
uncovered
so there's a lot of media coverage right
now the fact that many americans are
skeptical of coveted regulations
one of the reasons we are skeptical of
covert regulations is because the media
got this thing wrong
from the beginning they botched it every
way it was possible to watch it
first they said the thing was not
particularly dangerous in february when
they were saying that donald trump was
xenophobic for shutting down the borders
then they suggested that masks were
really not important and you shouldn't
wear them then they suggested the masks
were the most important thing that ever
was and that lockdowns were excellent
now they say well lockdowns are still
kind of excellent but they're not so
excellent if they apply to democrats
also they suggested in the middle of the
summer that millions of people
protesting in the streets and spitting
on each other over george floyd
suggesting that america was systemically
racist which is a lie
they suggested that that was good it was
a public health problem so they had a
they had a triple lie there i mean the
rare triple i
it's an olympic level triple i there
from the media one america's
systemically racist and that's why
there are disparities between black and
white particularly in policing two
if you go out and protest for george
floyd in the street that is riskier than
if you
go to an outdoor church service and more
important because it's a public health
problem
and three if you disagree with any of
that it's because you're a kova denier
so the rare triple lie it's like a
triple axel
it's amazing how the media could twist
themselves into pretzels and then they
wonder why don't they trust us
why don't they trust us and they engaged
in these sorts of lies over and over
about covet right andrew cuomo
incredible at his job chris cuomo on
there every night
doing doing buddy comedy with his bro
holding up giant weird props
to them to talk about the size of his
brother's nose while tens of thousands
of people died in his brother's steak
because
his brother was shipping old people with
covet back into nursing homes
and well now now we're supposed to trust
andrew cuomo again
and in that fun isn't fun how this works
if you feel like you are being
swiveled around like your head is now
being moved all the way around exorcism
style while you vomit in all directions
that's because that's what the media
have driven everybody to
so quick flashback first okay here is a
flashback this is from october
hey this is october good morning america
andrew cuomo the greatest governor in
america on covet
amazing governor and here he is
explaining he does not trust
a vaccine developed under the trump
administration
i'm not that confident but my opinion
doesn't matter i don't believe the
american people
are that confident you're going to say
to the american people now
here's a vaccine it was new it was done
quickly
but trust this federal administration
and their health
administration that it's safe
and we're not 100 percent sure of the
consequences
i think it's going to be a very
skeptical american public about taking
the vaccine and they should be
they should be skeptical about the
vaccine okay fast forward until after
the election
and now what is andrew cuomo the most
beloved governor of the media the
greatest governor in world history
saying about the vaccine here he is
again nothing changed nothing changed
people just voted for democrats
that's it okay in his opinion that's it
here is here is andrew cuomo completely
reversing himself
so i guess andrew cuomo is going to have
to fight andrew cuomo over the
credibility of the vaccine because here
he was yesterday
first we're gonna have to have a real
public education campaign to
battle the skepticism uh just think of
the math on this
you have to get the 75 percent to 85
of the overall population vaccinated for
the vaccine to be effective
75 to 85 fifty percent of the population
says right now they don't wanna take the
vaccine
uh they don't trust the approval process
uh
they're worried about vaccines in
general but fifty percent
are now saying they don't want to take
the vaccine you cannot get to
75 percent if 50
don't take it okay um the media said
this guy's an amazing governor
super consistent you'll click he won an
emmy guys he won a tv
emmy for his clarity and his wit in
presenting information to the public
let me explain something to both andrew
cuomo and the members of our esteemed
journalistic establishment
fire truck you
seriously you guys can just fire truck
right off
you can just just take a hike nobody's
interested in
in your opinions nobody believes you
when you say that your opinion is
separate from the facts
and nobody really believes you when you
say that you're any different than the
folks over at the daily wire because you
are objective while we are biased
of course we're biased because we're
honest you guys are damned liars
you're liars you like to project
any any damn narrative you want you will
suggest that joe biden has cured this
thing by the time we hit the end of
january that we're on the road to
recovery
using a vaccine developed under the
trump administration and a distribution
plan developed under the trump
administration you'll suggest
that joe biden has fixed everything oh
my god and we can all see it coming
we all know where this is going you will
suggest
that you guys were just the the reason
that that
that so many people voted for job items
because you were just so honest you did
the sort of journalistic work
that you should have been doing and you
will continue to pretend
that your back rub of joe biden which
will continue for as long as joe biden
is in office
and then any democrat is in office that
that back rub is really just hard
hitting journalism
no one believes you anymore and so now
you have to engage in the sort of
monopolistic behavior that
prevents anybody from seeing the
alternatives that's the goal
in the end that's the goal it's always
down to business it's it's
and here business meets ideology the the
authoritarians in your media don't want
you to see certain information and so
you didn't see it
the authoritarians in the media thought
that you were not capable of processing
information and making complex decisions
and so they simply prevented you
and your authoritarians in the media
were just upset at themselves because in
they accidentally covered the hillary
clinton emails and it may have cost
hillary clinton the election and so they
regret it
and you're starting to see i mean the
backlash on this sort of stuff to
members of the media who actually try to
be honest is astonishing
the other day joe biden completely blew
the name of his nominee for health and
human services secretary
xavier becerra he called him xavier
bakera
or something like that okay and a couple
members of the media noted this
other members of the media said how dare
you cover this
why would you cover this democracy is
under threat from trump
if you guys are just gonna work for the
democratic party then seriously go just
go get paid by the democratic party
don't pretend to be what you're not and
certainly don't try to shut down the
spigot of information so that everybody
else can see
the information that they want to see
okay meanwhile
it is it is incredible how the
democratic party is now going to
turn on people who are not wild leftists
so remember joe biden i mean speaking of
of just media bias in the extreme so for
the entire election cycle we were told
that if you mentioned that joe biden is
a senile old man which he clearly is
right see
joe biden is in decline it's perfectly
obvious that he is in decline
he's not full-scale senility like
thinking the curtains are talking to him
or something
but he just is not with it okay he makes
mistakes on a constant basis
he he fumbles his word i mean he's 78
that's not his fault
well first i would say that he's you
know i know a lot of 78 year olds who
are
in better mental shape than joe biden
but i know a lot of 78 year olds are in
worse mental shape than joe biden but
there's no question that joe biden now
is not what joe biden was even 10 years
ago
and joe biden 10 years ago with nothing
to write home about
joe biden 10 years ago was still an
incompetent buffoon who could barely
get a paragraph out of his mouth now
he's an even more incompetent buffoon
who can barely get a sentence out of his
mouth
but if you mention that then this is
because you are apparently an ageist or
because
you are not taking into account the fact
that he had a childhood stammer which of
course this is not about stammering this
is
uh i said before anybody who overcomes a
stammer
has engaged in an act of tremendous
courage and joe biden has helped out so
many people who have stammered
with advice and and comfort and all of
that it's not about that it's about the
fact
that if you believe the democrats do
that he's president elect of the united
states it sort of matters that the man
literally cannot say the names of the
members of his own cabinet without
stumbling over them okay if you
mentioned that
for the entirety of the election cycle
or now then it is suggested
that you are just your age-shaming
people which brings us
to a piece by jane mayer in the new
yorker
dianne feinstein's missteps raise a
painful age question among senate
democrats
i see you're not allowed to mention that
joe biden is 78 years old
because that's ageism but if you talk
about dianne feinstein this way
that's fine now i have a question what
changed about dianne feinstein what
changed over the past few weeks
can anybody think of it anybody any
questions any answers
hand up i see you in the back yes the
answer is zion feinstein hug lindsey
graham
that's what changed dianne feinstein who
is a
rabid militant democrat right she went
after brett kavanaugh with pretty much
everything she had
and she engaged in really corrupt
activities to do so bringing forth
narratives that simply had no factual
basis
but she had the temerity during the amy
coney barrett hearings to turn to
republicans and say you know what this
is actually kind of nice
we actually had like a normal judicial
hearing and that's kind of nice and then
she gave lindsey graham with whom she's
been in the senate for 1 000 years of
hug
this means she's senile and must be
booted from her positions in top
positions of
committee power according to jane mayer
reporting before the new yorker
in a hearing on november 17th dianne
feinstein the senior democrat on the
senate judiciary committee who at 87 is
the oldest member of the senate
grilled a witness reading from a chief
of prepared papers she asked jack dorsey
ceo of twitter whether his company was
doing enough to stem the spread of
disinformation
elaborating she read in full a tweet
president trump had disseminated on
november 7th
falsely claiming to have won the
presidential election she then asked
dorsey if twitter's labeling of the
tweet as disputed had adequately alerted
readers that it was a bald lie
it was a good question feinstein seemed
sharp and focused for decades she has
been the epitome of a female trailblazer
in washington always hyper prepared
but this time after dorsey responded
feinstein asked him the same question
again
reading it word for word along with the
trump tweet her inflection was early
identical
feinstein looked and sounded just as
authoritative seemingly registered
no awareness that she was repeating
herself verbatim dorsey graciously
answered the question
all over again and this has led to
serious questions
serious questions about whether dianne
feinstein has lost it okay now
it may be possible that dianne feinstein
has lost it i'm just going to note that
the only way that you were allowed to
talk about this now
is because dianne feinstein has fallen
out of favor with the left wing of her
party
that's all that's happening here many
others familiar with feinstein's
situation describe her as seriously
struggling
say it has been evident for several
years speaking on background and with
respect for her accomplished career they
say her short-term memory has grown so
poor she often forgets she's been
briefed on a topic
accusing her staff of failing to do so
just after they have they described
feinstein as forgetting what she has
said
and getting upset when she can't keep up
one aid to another senator described
what he called a kabuki meeting in which
feinstein's staff tried to steer her
through a proposed piece of legislation
that she protested was just words which
words which made no sense feinstein's
staff has said she sometimes
seems herself other times unreachable
the staff's in such a bad position a
former senate aide who still has
business in congress said
they have to defend her and make her
seem normal
so this means that it's time to get rid
of her obviously obviously dianne
feinstein
is buried in this piece the internal
criticism grew more intense this fall
over feinstein's handling of amy coney
barrett feinstein had bungled the
question about abortion during barrett's
2017 appeals court confirmation hearing
provoking conservative indignation by
casting it clumsily is a question about
barrett's extreme religious beliefs
the backlash over her question about
coney barrett effectively indemnified
barrett from further questions about how
her faith
affected her judicial rulings according
to several sources chuck schumer
democratic minority leader was so
worried feinstein would mismanage
barrett's confirmation hearings he
installed a trusted former aide max
young
to embed in the judiciary committee to
make sure the hearings didn't go off the
rails
he did the same during the kavanaugh
confirmation schumer brought young in
from the gun control group every town to
handle strategy and communications
and serve as schumer's eyes and ears on
feinstein as one source puts it
schumer's office declined to comment the
precaution failed nonetheless
to democrats dismay feinstein instead
hugged the republican chairman of the
committee lindsey graham
thanking him for his fairness and for
running one of the best set of hearings
that i've participated in
so clearly this was a failure and this
means that she's crazy
it can't just be that she handled it i
was actually supposed to be handled
you know in normal bipartisan fashion
like most judicial nominees
it was that she was bad and she was
senile now she became senile so you have
brian fallon the executive director of
the progressive advocacy group
demand justice he says it's time for
senator feinstein to step down from her
leadership
position on the senate judiciary
committee if she won't her colleagues
need to intervene and apparently schumer
then chided her
overtures were made to enlist the help
of feinstein's husband richard blum
okay so let me just point this out let's
say susan collins were like 10 years
older
15 years older and let's say that she
were making overtures to people on the
left side of the aisle
and let's say that people on the right
were like you know what maybe she's
senile and mitch mcconnell called her up
and then calls her husband
to try and pressure her you think the
media would be like oh probably she's
senile or do you think the media would
be more like
i can't believe they're trying to
pressure this person who is a bipartisan
hero
into giving up her positions look at
these extreme right wingers
and their militarization of age
it's it's just it's incredible stuff but
but you know our media perfectly
consistent across the board on this
dianne feinstein's great her great sin
here
is that she wasn't sufficiently woke she
wasn't sufficiently radical
speaking of the sufficiently woke and
sufficiently radical that wing of the
democratic party
is in the ascendancy raphael warnock
running for senate
in the state of georgia every day a new
clip from raphael warnock who is a
marxist
a marxist crazy person so this one is
from
raphael warnock describing castro's cuba
as very much like america
you know except for the fact that all
dissidents are thrown in prison and the
fact that people
literally get on 1950s chevys and try to
float their way from cuba to florida
that sort of stuff happens in the united
states all the time let me tell you the
way that i got to cal
the way i got to florida from california
is i actually took a tire and i jumped
onto it in l.a and then i just hoped
that the tide would sort of carry me all
the way through the gulf
and go through the panama canal and
everything and then i would end up in
florida i did that because
you know america's so oppressive and
terrible alternatively cuba is nothing
like the united states which is one of
the reasons why cuban americans vote
republican
to the great consternation of all the
democrats who think that if they say
latinx
that a bunch of latinos are going to
vote for them got a side note here i was
talking to a couple of the
latina members of the daily wire staff
before the show we were all laughing at
the stupidity of this latinx nonsense i
had to be informed
my producer savvy who is indeed a latina
woman
that latinx was supposed to be a
gender-neutral thing
because apparently democrats are afraid
that if they say latino
latino is used as the as the
plural right latinos is used as the
plural masculine but it's also
it covers the feminine also when you see
latinos it covers masculine and feminine
it's sort of like
in in hebrew write a language i know
much better than spanish
in hebrew when you say jews you say
yehudim right
the eem at the end is a masculine suffix
okay but it covers everybody
when when you say people you say anashim
right eem is the masculine suffix
right oat would be the female suffix not
to get into linguistics here but eem
covers
male and female right apparently the
same holds true in spanish
okay so democrats were so afraid that
this would piss off latina
women that they made up latinx with
tanks
or tanks which is the stupidest thing
anyone has ever heard of
and people who are actually latino laugh
at this they think it's the dumbest
thing in the world
but this is where democrats are and then
they can't believe that
latinos are voting in larger and larger
numbers over time for republicans
i mean they certainly can't believe that
cuban americans consistently vote for
republicans
one of the reasons is because you keep
running jokers like raphael warnock
here's raphael warnock in georgia
we pray for the people of cuba in this
moment
we remember fidel castro whose legacy
is complex don't let anybody tell you a
simple story life
usually isn't very simple
his legacy is complex
kind of like america's legacy is complex
no actually his legacy is not complex he
took over
an island nation with a few hundred
people
and then he proceeded to ram down a
communist dictatorship on
generations of human beings
impoverishing them and turning one of
the richer countries
in the entire latin american sphere into
basically a hell hole for people to live
in again
you don't try to escape great places by
getting on an old chevy and trying to
float 90 miles to the coast of florida
typically not a thing that you do
so democrats running that guy definitely
by the way republicans in georgia vote
against that guy i don't care what you
think happened
in the presidential election in georgia
go out and vote against that
you don't want that in the senate by the
way he also said that benjamin netanyahu
was basically a nazi the the prime
minister of israel he said that he was
like an apartheid south africa
racist and all that he called him he
compared him to george wallace i believe
was the actual quote he compared him to
george wallace
the jews like george wallace raphael
warnock you might want to vote against
that
this is the the new face that diane
feinstein's too old this is the new face
of the democratic party karen bass who's
widely considered a possible
vp pick for joe biden early on she
went on cnn yesterday and she says that
policing is very obvious to americans
that policing is an issue of systemic
racism
oh yes this is going to be your
democratic party from now until
the foreseeable future here she was
considering the historical moment that
we're in
post-george floyd where people finally
in the united states understand that the
issue of policing
is a question of systemic racism we
understand because of covet
the underlying health conditions and so
we have
real issues in this country and what we
saw over the last few months
is that maybe we can address some of
these issues i think it makes
absolute sense to do that at the highest
level
every crisis is an opportunity to cram
down a social justice viewpoint on the
world
for the radical democrats and anyone who
stands in their way becomes
an enemy i will say there are certain
lines that even the radicals uh will
cross at a certain point
so apparently portland's mayor has now
evicted a new
red house autonomous zone by forces
emily's
riots for a inaudib straight nights a
hundred straight nights you think that
might be a national news story just a
little bit
there are riots for a hundred straight
nights in portland and everybody's like
well you know that's just portland
they're kind of kooky they like hemp
clothing and they wear birkenstocks
they're weird but you know it's like a
kooky fun thing
rioting every night for a hundred nights
well according to emily's annotti
portland oregon mayor
ted wheeler sent the city's police force
to evict a new autonomous
zone that cropped up around an
anti-eviction protest on tuesday
reversing a month-long policy of
tolerating ongoing demonstrations even
when they turn violent
protesters have been camping out for
months to prevent the eviction of the
kinney family on tuesday morning
tensions escalated
protesters used fences and barricades
set up by law enforcement officials to
surround the home
which has been renamed the red house on
mississippi due to its location
on mississippi avenue according to
newsweek videos of the autonomous zone
appeared on twitter showing a shanty
town made of cardboard boxes and
pilfered public fencing with warning
signs posted
on the outside reports indicated that a
few dozen protesters
plan to take up residence in the
autonomous zone surrounding the red
house
the family owes a hundred thousand
dollars on the home the bank foreclosed
protesters believed that the family
should not be forced out during a
pandemic and that the bank was seeking a
swifter eviction because the property
next to the home
recently sold for more than seven
figures when the city refused to honor
protesters demands they organized an
autonomous zone like chaz shop in
seattle
and even this was a little too
humiliating for mayor ted wheeler so he
authorized portland police to break the
thing up
shortly before 5 am on wednesday morning
the portland police and the multnomi
noma county sheriff began their property
mission reclaiming the land on which
protesters had set up the autonomous
zone they said it was not simply a
protest they were dismantling
apparently there was a stockpile of
weapons and the presence of firearms
according to portland's police chief
chuck lovell he says we're aware of the
threats of the community to media and to
police
we've seen the attacks the portland
police will enforce the law and use
force if necessary to restore order
to the neighborhood well i'm glad that
they finally realized that there was one
bridge that was too far for them
but you literally have to get to the
point for democrats of threatening
violence before people are like oh maybe
this is maybe this person shouldn't be
like a mainstream part
of our coalition alrighty now i do have
to bring you
an update on the 2020 election a lot of
focus being put
on this final sort of texas but it's
sort of a last-ditch bid by team trump
to stop the certification of the
election
according to cnbc 17 states whose
elections were won by president trump
told the supreme court on wednesday they
support a texas attorney general ken
paxton's bid
to file a lawsuit that could effectively
reverse biden's projected electoral
college victory
the filing backing packs in by the
states came a day after he asked the
supreme court for permission to georgia
michigan pennsylvania and wisconsin
all of which biden purportedly won over
their voting processes
later on wednesday trump filed a motion
to intervene in the case in his personal
capacity
as a presidential candidate these states
are basically saying that if other
states vote unfairly
they are being deprived of equal
protection under the law so texas is
basically saying for example that if
pennsylvania screws up its voting
procedure it outweighs our ability to
vote fairly so we voted fairly they
voted unfairly
therefore democrats stole that and
therefore we have a stake in the
national election
it's a hard legal argument to make
the the 17 former officials and
lawmakers filed their own brief
supporting these the the four swing
states they said the constitution does
not make the supreme court the
multi-district litigation panel
for trials of presidential election
disputes so in other words
states get to make their own voting
procedures and other states cannot sue
those states
for their voting procedures this was
actually just an attempt to elevate this
thing to the supreme court that was
really the idea here
because again under the under the
constitution
then controversies between states are
typically adjudicated by the supreme
court or can be adjudicated by the
supreme court but for a controversy to
arrive between the states you actually
have to make a plausible federal claim
most legal experts think that this thing
is basically doomed
to failure andy mccarthy who is an ally
of
president trump's and has been a big
defender of trump throughout his
administration he has a piece over at
national review
pointing out that this lawsuit is
unlikely to go anywhere
he says the first thing to notice about
texas's lawsuit
is what does not appear on the front
page the name of the state's solicitor
general kyle hawkins
the lawsuit is brought against four
other states thus attorney general ken
paxton
invokes the original jurisdiction of the
u.s supreme court to hear disputes
between the states but the brief is not
signed by the lawyer who typically
represents texas when there is a supreme
court case
that's because this thing has no
prospect of winning according to andy
mccarthy
he says there's a lot to be said for
texas's complaint as a political polemic
it's true democrats labor mightily to
undermine election integrity the only
rational reason for that is to make it
easier for legally unqualified people to
cast ballots and to cast them in bulk
the ballots of people would not
otherwise have voted it's also true mail
and voting on a massive scale creates
tremendous potential for fraud
this potential is inevitably realized
and at least some fraud when coupled
with other policies that democrats like
by getting rid of id
or signature verification witness
requirements ballot harvesting
all of these matters should be addressed
by congress and by state lawmakers says
andy mccarthy
but none of them give state the texas
the standing to sue
other states over the manner in which
they do elections again in order to have
a case or controversy
you have to demonstrate standing then
you have to show that you have been
damaged
right if colton gets hit by a car i
can't sue the person who drove the car
on behalf of colton i don't have
standing colton members of colton family
would have to
sue presumably says annie mccarthy this
does not mean the flouting of election
laws by officials in pennsylvania and
other states is not a serious issue
it means that if texas wants to raise
that issue the supreme court is not the
right forum
to report to repeat a point i've made
before the court did not grant review of
a case from pennsylvania it should have
taken
involving a narrow critical issue of
constitutional law pertaining to
elections
when that issue was raised by parties in
the commonwealth who were directly
affected
the justices are not going to have
interest in entertaining a sprawling
lawsuit brought by an unaffected
third-party state
he says he thinks that in all likelihood
they're just gonna
throw this thing out it's also a problem
because
it actually creates the legal predicate
if the supreme court were to take it
it would actually create the legal
predicate for any state swing another
state
for any supposed impact on the first
state so for example california could
sue alabama over alabama's abortion laws
saying that california provides abortion
alabama does not provide abortion
and therefore that affects california
because people are traveling from
alabama to california to have abortions
and it is creating strain on their
system right you could see people making
those sorts of claims
this is why you have pretty strict rules
in terms of what is a case or
controversy and what standing
constitutes so it's unlikely that this
is going to
go anywhere according to annie mccarthy
federal law provides a procedure under
which on january 6th
congress will convene to count the
electoral votes if texas's elected
representatives object to the counting
of any state's electoral votes congress
will hear debate and vote
on those objections at that point
there's no way however the supreme court
will entertain that texas lawsuit so
it's important that you know that going
in
so that we know exactly what is coming
down the road
there's still one outstanding lawsuit in
georgia that one
has plausible claims to make i'll be
fascinated to see how georgia secretary
of state responds to very specific
allegations that are made in the georgia
lawsuit
about not only the violation of election
protocol but also
about specific voters who should not
have voted i mean there's like giant
lists of them
included in this georgia lawsuit so that
one is the one to watch in terms of
lawsuits that have a chance
of going anywhere okay we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton